it's National coding week and a local
tutoring facility shows us how important
it is to learn more about digital
literacy new East West Academy is now
offering coding classes in addition to
the many tutoring subjects already
available Victoria Saha has more tonight
it's 2022 everything we use has some
sort of technological aspect towards it
but have you wondered what goes behind
it coding this teaches you The Logical
thinking process how how do the computer
thinks how we think with it how to use
it Bruce Bommarito and his wife CEO
Susan Wong has stored a new East West
Academy in 2018 offering tutoring
classes such as Chinese chess and math
inspired by the academic options they
wish their twin daughters would have in
school we want to offer some of the give
our own children some good programs to
enrich their school curriculum and this
fall they're offering coding search of
the World We compare with the other
programs in town we found this one first
win to Europe and it really prepares you
to learn any language the family says
they believe in offering non-traditional
courses in their after-school facility
to let students reach their fullest
potential Victoria zaha 8 news now
classes start at forty dollars for an
hour and a half 15 class courses can
cost up to 800 bucks but it's because
coding week they are giving away two
spots for free